as the trial of derek shovin continues
nearly two weeks into the proceedings
it's as clear as ever that the trial of
derek chauvin doesn't really matter to
the people who
demanded that he'd be put on trial from
the very moment that they saw the
infamous video
last may for the media blm the left
generally
the trial is but a formality a bit of a
symbolic theater
they arrived at their conclusion when
they watched the video probably even
before they watched it in many cases
and the only point of the trial is to
affirm that conclusion
it's not to prove anything proof is
irrelevant truth is irrelevant
for this crowd the truth is whatever
they feel and the job of the rest of the
world is to validate those feelings
that's how they approach all of life and
that certainly includes the court system
and it's why we now are living under a
terrorist threat
from these same people we all know that
they'll riot
and kill and burn destroy if they don't
get their way every person in the
country knows this
and we're meant to accept it we're meant
to simply cope with the fact that we now
live in a country where
if one side of the ideological divide is
ever made very mad about something
they'll kill people and burn down
buildings and be allowed to do it given
space to do it to use the former
baltimore mayor's phrase give them space
to destroy
she said we're also supposed to tolerate
and accept that the left is
using terrorist threats to influence the
outcome of a murder trial
blm activists and others have not been
veiled or subtle
about this at all if they don't get
their way
they'll destroy your neighborhood maybe
kill you in the process
that's the threat and we know they'll
really do it because they've
already done it many times what this
means is that the well
has already been poisoned you know if
the jury finds chauvin guilty
it could very easily be because they
don't want to cause rioting
and they know that an acquittal would
would bring that
also they don't want they don't want to
worry about being doxxed and their lives
permanently ruined and endangered
because of it
because we know that's also going to
happen now
maybe if they come back with a guilty
verdict it'll be because that's how they
honestly read and interpreted the facts
of the case
that could also be it but we'll never be
able to know that
we'll never know to what extent the
terrorist threats
influence the outcome of the trial if
they come back with a guilty verdict
ironically then the only outcome the
only verdict we can trust
is an acquittal we know if they find
guilty
it would very well it could very well be
because of terrorist threats
not necessarily but it that could be the
reason or part of the reason
if they acquit it will be in spite of
the terrorist threats they'll be finding
that way in spite of the fact
that they risk their own lives in doing
so there couldn't be any
feasible motivation to come to that
decision other than
that it's the correct decision in their
view so that's what we're faced with
this is what the left has done to this
country in one of the highest profile
murder cases in modern american history
perhaps the most type the highest
profile of all
the only verdict that we can be sure was
arrived at honestly and based on the
facts of the case
is the very verdict that would cause our
cities to burn
it's the double-edged sword of all
double-edged swords
a consequence of living in a country
where millions of people
have just thrown truth out the window
and morality out the window
but for those of us who still care about
the truth and who are following this
case and actually evaluating the
evidence on its own merits
whatever small portion of people fall
into that category for those people
i think it's important to emphasize one
important and um and
and simple point this is a point that
has been totally lost in the media
coverage and even many of the seemingly
honest people i've talked to
who really want to know the truth in
this case and really want true justice
to be done
one way or another seem to have
forgotten or lost sight of this
and and and the point is this reasonable
doubt
okay that's the standard i'm not a
lawyer not a legal expert or a legal
scholar but i know that much
because that's simple that's basic level
derek chovin's
lawyer doesn't need to prove
that chauvin is innocent all he needs to
do is demonstrate that there is
reasonable doubt about his guilt all he
has to establish is that the prosecution
has not
fully established its own case if you're
sitting on the jury and you say to
yourself when all is said and done well
i think he really might have killed
floyd but it's also plausible that he
didn't
that should be a vote to acquit i mean
we don't convict people or we aren't
supposed to convict people
in this country based on mites and
maybes
uh they maybe i think he probably did
but we'll convict them that's not the
way it's supposed to work we convict
based on
certainty beyond all reasonable doubt
now the prosecution is still making its
case the defense hasn't even really
begun to present its own case but so far
based on what we
what we based on what we knew going into
the trial and what has come out during
the trial
there is so far a whole heap of
reasonable doubt
you know the prosecution says that
chauvin acted negligently and used
excessive force which led directly to
floyd's death
but the defense has been able to show
just by examining the prosecution's own
witnesses that the force he used
may not have been excessive in fact one
expert prosecution witness admitted on
the stand
that chauvin would have been justified
in using even more force he could have
used a taser on floyd for example
and would have been justified in doing
so you could argue that chauvin was
more restrained in his handling of floyd
than he needed to be you could argue
that
we've also seen and this again has come
out during questioning of prosecution
witnesses
that there was a hostile crowd at the
scene and this impacts the way officers
handle a suspect
we've seen that floyd was resisting was
belligerent was complaining that he
couldn't breathe
even before he was on the ground we've
seen that floyd had three times
three times the lethal dose of fentanyl
in his system
another prosecution witness testified
that floyd was foaming at the mouth
now once again this is a prosecution
witness supposed to be helping the
prosecution's case
saying that he saw floyd foaming at the
mouth
well is that more likely to be a sign of
someone overdosing or
of them being choked to death
yesterday the defense played a clip of
floyd apparently sang i ate too many
drugs
now you could hear that clip and argue
that he didn't say that
that he might have said something else
but i ate too many drugs as at least a
plausible interpretation of the clip you
don't have to strain very hard to say
yeah it sounds like he said that maybe
he didn't but it sounds like he did
that's all that matters is there a
plausible scenario where chauvin is
entirely innocent of causing floyd's
death
so far yes here's the scenario floyd
took three times the fatal
dose of a dangerous narcotic overdosed
and died
i mean that's the plausible scenario
it's consistent with the facts
there's evidence to support it and the
prosecution hasn't disproved it beyond a
reasonable doubt they haven't even begun
to disprove it
haven't gotten close to disproving it
there's more trial yet to be had but you
know there's enough
at this point enough reasonable doubt to
cover chauvin with some left over
in fact there's so much reasonable doubt
at this point that the real question is
why the case was even brought in the
first place
a man with three times a failed dose of
a narcotic in his system died
while foaming at the mouth speculation
that chauvin
may have still been part of the cause
but not the cause or even the main cause
is not enough to convict a man of murder
in this country
or at least it shouldn't be
doesn't mean you have to believe chauvin
is innocent doesn't mean you have to
like him
it doesn't mean you have to invite him
over for dinner it just means that
reasonable
doubt is the standard and that standard
matters
our justice system is built on it we
don't have a justice system without it
we don't have justice without it
but then again the people shouting no
justice no peace
they don't care about justice do they
vengeance is what they're after
and they're determined to get it get
their vengeance
one way or another well i hope you
enjoyed that clip for the matt well show
if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content